[Music]
foreign
hello welcome to next 22.
my prediction is by the end of 2025
developers will start with neural
inclusive design we'll see a 5x growth
in user adoption in their first two
years in production here at Google we
believe the world and our workplace
needs all types of thinkers
what do you think about that Jim
that's right one in five of us here
today are Nero distinct but what is Nero
inclusive design
ER occlusa design is designed for
cognitive and sensory accessibility so
narrow inclusive design starts with
raising accessibility for neurodistinct
people like myself
but everyone benefits
design principles can be made
near-inclusive when you plan
thoughtfully for balance proportion
Unity light color space and patterns
my name is Eric Brewer and my prediction
is that by the end of 2025 four out of
five Enterprise developers we use some
form of curated open source what I mean
by that is curated open source comes
with support for developers we believe
in this philosophy so much that we are
already working on it
to help you build the care apps faster
we're releasing software delivery Shield
this is a fully managed security
solution that protects your software
supply chain from source to deployment
and as part of SDS we have our initial
curated open search example called
assured OSS
this service curates open source
packages used by Google and makes it
available to you our Cloud Developers
Google scan analyze and fuzz test more
than 250 Java and python packages for
security vulnerabilities on your behalf
and we'll update them as needed
my name is Iman ganizada and my
prediction is that by the end of 2025 90
of security operations workflows will be
automated and managed as code
okay so secops teams are struggling to
keep up with the attackers we all know
this right there's there's too much data
complex technology environments and
there's more adversaries now more than
ever so to scale security across Cloud
we're going to make security more agile
and accessible to everyone through code
our autonomic security operations
framework is designed to help you take
advantage of our API first approach with
Chronicle security operations and other
tools including many of those tools that
are within our new mandian portfolio
this shift in our new framework takes
traditional assembly line security
operations workflows into a codified
continuous feedback model we call
continuous detection continuous response
or cdcr for short
hi my name is Camilia aryafar and my
prediction is by the end of 2025 AI is
going to be the primary driver for
moving to a four day work week
thank you
Enterprise use of AI alone exploded over
the past few years touching all aspects
of business one of the greatest reasons
behind this is ai's huge potential to
increase employee productivity with
vertex AI data scientists can now build
and train ml models five times faster
meaning increased time for
experimentation reduce custom coding and
the ability to move more ml models into
production
today with the announcement of vertex AI
Vision we are taking this a step further
and providing you with a fully managed
development environment for creating
computer vision applications
I'm Irina Farooq and my prediction is
that by the end of 2025 90 of data will
be actionable in real time using ml a
recent survey found that only one-third
of all companies are able to realize
tangible value from their data
first you can't act on data unless you
can see it and trust it that's why I'm
particularly excited about the new data
quality and lineage capabilities and
dataplex
bringing intelligence and automation to
help you trust your data
second you can't act on data unless you
can work with it I'm excited about
bigquery's new support for unstructured
data
now you can be sure that you can your
bigquery skills will pay off across all
your data from structure to
semi-structured to unstructured
lastly you can't act on today's data
tomorrow data flow a streaming analytics
service Powers critical Google services
and we believe it can do the same for
you
hi I'm Andy Goodmans and I predict that
by the end of 2025 the barriers between
transactional and analytical workloads
will disappear are transactional and
analytical databases are built on a
highly scalable disaggregated compute
and storage system and Google's high
performance Global Network allowing us
to provide tightly integrated data
services
First Data stream for bigquery which
allows you to easily replicate data from
transactional databases into bigquery in
real time
next database migration service which
provides a one-click migration from
postgres into alloy DB for operational
Analytics
and lastly we support query Federation
with spanner Cloud SQL and bigtable
right from the bigquery console to
analyze data in transactional databases
my name is Amin vadat and my prediction
is by the end of 2025 over half of cloud
infrastructure decisions will be
automated based on organization's usage
patterns to meet performance and
reliability needs
this is called an infrastructure
Processing Unit or ipu and it gives you
massive performance and scalability
to power high performance data intensive
apps
these ipus are at the heart of our new
C3 VMS meet the hardware behind the new
tensor Processing Unit the TPU V4
platform it's likely the world's fastest
largest and most efficient machine
learning supercomputer
this liquid-cooled board is a beast in
both power and performance density the
same ipus and tpus that power your
services are the foundation that will
enable us to automate over half of cloud
infrastructure decisions in the next
couple of years
hi my name is Taran janini and my
prediction is that by the end of 2025
three out of four developers will lead
with sustainability as their primary
development principle
65 percent of it Executives said they
want to improve their sustainability
efforts but don't know how to do it
we can give them better data about the
environmental footprint of their
business right from the cloud console
you can access the carbon footprint
dashboard of your account
name is Richard sirroder my prediction
for you today is that by the end of 2025
over half of all organizations using
public Cloud were actually going to
freely switch their primary Cloud as a
result of all these new multi-cloud
capabilities available but here at
Google Cloud we've made some unique
investments in a multi-cloud management
plane that works with your compute and
your data even if it's on other clouds
you'll see here I actually have an eks
cluster I built and I've actually
attached this to the anthos control
plane from here I can manage the cluster
I can view workloads I can deploy things
I can troubleshoot I can apply common
policies as I start using Google cloud
services I want to use it even more and
more so I might introduce things like
amp those clusters to Azure and AWS this
is the gke API and gke software running
across clouds which is amazing and just
now we just shipped the capability where
I can even upgrade those clusters in
place on another cloud from the Google
Cloud console that's awesome I don't
have to jump all over the place to run
all my infrastructure now what's really
cool is you may also continue to use
anthos on Google Cloud
to manage all of your fleets of gke
clusters at all of our regions around
the world I'm showing you some new
dashboards here that are coming out and
this actually actually lets me manage
not just my gke clusters but I'm
managing on-prem bare metal VMware Edge
doesn't matter I'm getting a view of my
entire fleet managing that I'm Jana
mandich and my prediction is that by the
end of 2025 over half of all business
applications will be built by users who
do not identify as professional
developers today
the adoption of no Code and low code
tools will unlock this potential by
making the development process easier
for more users
well with these tools those business
users you had to say no to can instead
create apps and workflow automations
themselves with no programming skills
required
these no Code and low code apps will be
built collaboratively with developers
like you who will provide the guard
rails to keep the business secure while
enabling business users to deliver their
own Solutions
remember if you want to share your own
prediction use the hashtag Google
cloudpredictions to tell us all about it
we can't wait to hear from you
[Music]